where are we Philadelphia wow it's an
all-day program today you know if you
can survive when you set a goal for
yourself when you tell yourself you're
gonna do it you have to do it
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good morning welcome to day one I guess
of our trip last night we got and really
late we mess up not bad we are in where
are we where are we Phoenixville
Pennsylvania getting ready to hop an
uber and get some food and head to our
event with Satguru I'm gonna take you on
a journey with us
so I've eaten a lot of crap over the
past couple days airplane and just in
general lots of crap so I've decided at
least for now I'm doing 30 minutes of
cardio a day I ran on the spot this
morning when Lena did her makeup and I'm
fasting until noon Nina's not fasting
she's hungry she's hungry I'm fasting
until noon
so hopefully that helps I feel a little
bit better already actually just doing
the run and having some water so we'll
see this is the my new experiment Papa
ruber go to the convention center but
first get Nina food so she doesn't get
angry
okay we made it into where are we
Philadelphia Wow
okay new whatever an even wants to eat I
still have an hour before I'm allowed to
eat self-imposed allowed self-imposed
allowed so we're gonna try to find some
food in this strip mall and then head to
our inner engineering
I'm not seeing a Starbucks for Nina Nina
what are you gonna do we need to make
Nina have a big smile on her face for
the Starbucks stretch it out stretch it
out
[Music]
hey we found it look Nina look at the
smile let's see the sign Lena let's see
the style there it is hey
[Music]
how is it yeah yeah me you get some food
should we get some snacks for the event
don't we need snacks yeah maybe not I
think we should have just some emergency
snack just in case
I like being prepared so trying to find
something that we can bring in sneak in
just in case
looking at these granola options
something that's not too messy maybe
some bars Oh Nina found something Kashi
bars okay I was just saying maybe some
bars okay the kids goldfish now look
here I have to close it but the bars I
get how about some mixed nuts yeah
Deluxe roasted and mixed nuts yeah looks
good I like that
salt for sure we're salt sea salt Oh
unsalted no Nina has a really big
appetite for salt it's actually me who
like salt more if I get a headache salt
is what really helps me so it's good
okay
okay I'm feeling it I'm feeling it we're
making progress it's 11:55
decisions what if I got a hoarder what
am I gonna eat decisions yeah but what
I'm gonna order get it you gotta make
some decisions
so I got a turkey bacon little sandwich
here and instead of going coffee I just
went smoothie what do we think me man I
don't know feeling healthy
[Music]
it is bright it is hot Nino's getting
cold in there yeah
Oh your hands are freezing don't touch
me don't touch me okay we finished the
breakfast slash lunch we're gonna head
to the islands a studio but it's not the
Convention Center we're not allowed to
film inside so maybe you'll grab a quick
screenshot or something there a photo of
the outside and then give you our our
feelings and and stuff okay that's how
professionals talk I don't know it's so
cold
me too there okay good wait okay good
it's 12:30 right now we the thing starts
at 2:00 but it's first-come first-serve
so we've got to go in and get our seats
we're gonna go all the way until 7:30 no
filming I don't think this breaks you
goes from 3 to 7:30 they want us on an
empty stomach
empty empty empty by 5 o'clock for an
exercise so we'll see how that goes
Nina's very excited
we brought some water and what what else
that's it that's it we'll see you on the
other side fingers crossed
[Music]
it's Nina we are coming out of the one
like they missed everything right you
guys missed everything it's kind of
weird on the blog to say what's
happening
so maybe what we'll do is well it will
pop in some highlights from the site go
to top ten with success you see get a
flavor for what we did today there is no
best thing to do in life anything that
you take up and if you put your heart
and soul into it it becomes a great
thing if you want to be in a competitive
situation the thing is you have to work
on your competence we're getting rained
on hey this wouldn't be a caracal
vacation or that for that rain right
Lisa's warm right don't have to wear the
sweater you just got some believe gear
to keep her warm we're gonna go get some
dinner
Nina's hungry there's some Chinese food
Chinese food Chinese food we have to be
here at 6:30 tomorrow and it's gonna go
from 6:30 in the morning to 8:00
something at night what are we gonna
film for the vlog tomorrow tomorrow's
gonna be hey guys we're really tired
it's the morning and we can't have
coffee and then it's gonna be oh my god
it's nine o'clock what happened today
yeah well we'll see we'll see what kind
of fun stuff we can do on tomorrow's
episode but for now let's get some food
all right we finally made it
Nina's Choice come eita Asian Bistro
where you gonna get Nina
all right Haitian cuisine it says sushi
there's sushi or or we go to Cheeburger
Cheeburger another option
you don't want sushi you want to check
out the pub at the end you're not
feeling sushi Cheeburger Cheeburger no G
burger okay no no you prick you care
more about this affinity Cheeburger
sushi sushi
all right back Amita hey Lina I think we
should get the poopoo platter I just
like a name of the poopoo fighter
[Music]
there's your ice
there's my sweet and sour chicken what
you thinking let's go try that that's
put that's tiny that's pretty big now
neither's hungry but it's delicious oh
yeah alright that's actually that's a
legit genuine reaction good I'm excited
for my sweet sour chicken fortune cookie
time
what's your fortune Nina mine is do not
like great ambitions overshadow small
success I don't like that
[Music]
they mean place should be crazy of
course everybody half the people from
the more than half the people think from
the sadguru yeah a majority people are
Indian so there's an Indian restaurant
here that's that's rammed we're gonna
make a quick potential snack pit stop at
Target yeah
what are you feeling if we could get
something at Target what would it be
Nina wine you want a drink right Nina
wants a drink all right I'm gonna get
chocolate maybe fingers crossed get some
good food
[Applause]
no wine for Nina they don't sell wine I
guess is a geographic thing he said they
don't do it in the north the gas station
just started so in Canada they for sure
don't sell alcohol in in grocery stores
well they are they're starting them I
just I just don't buy alcohol so I don't
know but they don't do it in the
northern us we learned something there
Nina yeah we didn't get the alcohol but
we did get my snack York Peppermint
Patties yeah
[Music]
all right believe nation we made it back
to our resting place for the night we
got to wake up early tomorrow we have to
be there at 6:30 to check-in for 7:30
start it's about 9:30 now so we're gonna
go in get some sleep
Nina's final message of the day is relax
Wow okay well we hope that you will get
lots of relax a lot of typical message
you hear but every now and then you need
some good relax
thank you guys have a great night
what's up believe nation welcome today
to bless you of our spring trip so
yesterday was day one of Satguru we're
here in Philadelphia it was just kind of
introduction nina's what he did playing
the games in this planet game name is
obsessed with this game upset is that
car here oh that's a Cooper taking it
uber to get decide to do today is day
two today's the full day I don't think
we can even bring you guys inside
so we'll see we can film full-day
sadguru ahead here we go
how did you sleep last night
you woke up place and
1:30 woke up at 4:30 and then with him
to actually get up Thanks six it's an
all-day program today
you know if you can survive we'll see
we'll see I believe in you mean that the
program start 7:30 in the morning we
have to be there before that because
after 7:30 the doors closed and it's
gonna go until 8:00 8:00 8:00 at night
so it's a full day we have a little bit
of lunch break and some other Peaks I
think in between I burn for an entire
day
you excited doesn't sound like it Nina
we've got a week out then we'll be
excited
all right we're here time to go inside
they're gonna kick me off my phone no
more filming number of filming we can't
take you with us final words from Nina
here we go
so it always sucks you two doing the
vlog and you can't bring the audience
tonight with the group we came out we
are starving it's time to eat milk
Millie Millie Millie Millie it's Philly
plus-plus Nina is nilly Nina's never had
a Philly cheesesteak so it came to
Sunny's famous cheesesteak for Nina to
have her first one so you got the
classic which is the best for
out-of-towners never had one so there it
is no the insides you break it up
look at that containing that they could
bite they could bite
[Applause]
[Music]
misty Swiss cheese with steak and onions
I think that's what's in here okay my
Wow
thumbs up so we just got home very tired
long long day and I made a commitment
that I was going to run our do cardio
for at least 30 minutes every day and
got not eat anything until noon so those
two things when I come in for the trip
don't eat until noon and run or cardio
for 30 minutes a day which means I need
to do cardio for the next 30 minutes I'm
probably going to catch up on some
League of Legends watching while I run
and my calves are burning
probably from sitting all day I'm not
used to sitting cross-legged all day so
much so yeah this will be a fun half an
hour but this is important guys when you
set a goal for yourself when you tell
yourself you're gonna do it you have to
do it every time you what you got to do
it Nina's in the bathroom yelling you
got to do it I don't think we heard you
but I said it for you when you set a
goal and you don't do it you teach
yourself that it's okay to set goals and
not follow through and when you set a
goal and it's difficult and you do it
you build so much positive momentum and
you build into the identity that you
were the kind of person who sets goals
and follows through so it is late
it's been a long crazy day my calves are
burning we got to wake up at 3:00 what
tomorrow morning at 3:00 we're gonna
wake up at 3:00 to morning taking it to
the airport but I set a goal and so I
need to run for half an hour here we go
[Music]
who workout done time for shower bed and
wake up at 3:00 then taking it to the
airport
thank you for joining Nina Nina final
message Nina does not have a final
message for you today she's busy but
we'll see her tomorrow at three and one
and two thank you guys for the love bit
of a strange vlog but I hope you enjoyed
it I believe in you hope you can you to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is we read the book much love
I'll see you soon